[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interviews YouTube channel
where I have a wonderful excuse to talk
about one of my favorite movies of 2022
with director Dan Trachtenberg pray yet
again I get to say congratulations thank
you uh uh you are one of my favorite
people um
channels
so it's a
I love hearing it I have a quick
unrelated question the the piece behind
you what is it what does it represent
what is it supposed to be that is it's
like written right there uh it's 10
Cloverfield Lane
um
there's a site called movie palette
well funny enough so I or this was on
the site which was so cool to see
and then I looked up pray pray was not
on the site and so I reached out there's
a there's a custom you could do like a
custom option so I filled in prey 2023
you know and they wrote back and saying
sorry we can't do this movie you know
and I was like well I made it like is
there anything I can do to like help and
uh and they got her back like oh okay uh
well we just needed like in this file
and I I got them the file like oh it's
too big and like you literally went back
and forth like trying to make it happen
so I have I have in another room pray
um and the karate the original Karate
Kid as well it's very it's very
meaningful to my wife and I yeah you're
a big Karate Kid fan so are you into are
you into Cobra Kai as well love Cobra
Kai love those guys yeah I I I actually
helped out a little in I just I've done
the boys with with Elizabeth Shoe and
the pilot
um and I directed The Pilot for that and
and uh and she they she had just been
asked about the show and was like I
don't know that you know and I was like
are you it's so good like I freaked out
over it
um and then reached out to the guys uh
that do it and we all strategize them
how to convince Lisa's shoe to like to
do it um so
uh yes I love the show I'm so glad you
helped spark that because her return to
COBRA Kai was done so exceptionally I
like I I knew the show's track record
and how good they were at bringing back
elements from a popular franchise but
her addition in particular was most
nervous about and they absolutely nail
it and she she was nervous too she had
she had a very
uh tragic uh you know situation even in
the first and part two and not returning
um and so was very nervous about how it
was in it's a totally different
perspective
on that movie that we not not really you
know it was for all of them was a silly
movie with a silly name
um we all fell in love with it but but
we didn't all fall in love with Ali with
a knot she was the cheerleader she
represented a very specific kind of
female role in 80s movies that we
quickly kind of forget about because of
our deep affection for the for that
movie
um and so I I agree the guys handled it
really well
um and uh and once she sparked to it you
know and realized what they were doing I
think it made it a no-brainer but yeah I
was going to save a question like this
for closer to the end but given we're
talking about uh Karate Kid and Cobra
Kai now I wanted to mention that someone
on uh collider wrote a really nice piece
about you the title of it was prey shows
Dan trachtenberg's gift for transforming
franchises and it's all about you know
celebrating how you're able to re revamp
and reinvigorate existing franchises and
and I will agree with the piece I think
you do it exceptionally well so after
Cloverfield field and now Predator if
you had the opportunity to do it again
what franchise would you pick and why
um
I legally can't answer that oh I like
that answer no I mean there's there are
there are some I definitely am you know
I continue continue to
work on things that are not franchise
related and that are that are very
unique properties in their own way and
things that are branches related but
still
the like even in the attempt to in
thinking about what might be next inside
this franchise
I I thought a lot about a lot of times
we have a very bold
uh the first movie or or a sequel
um and then they make a sequel from that
that is just the next thing as opposed
to no the next one should also be let's
make them all bold and exciting and you
know so that's what we've given a lot of
thought too if there were to be more of
this
um and then there are some out there
that are like how the heck do you do
that's the most exciting thing
um are all the nuts I haven't cracked
but I think I think about those more
than more than the things that I'm
actually working on you know because
there's such challenges of and that's
the fun that's the thrill that frankly
you know my way into into
movies from from commercials and
podcasting initially was doing that the
a short based on portal which the
interest was like nobody's thinking of
that as a movie at the time now that
everyone all the news was about
Uncharted and Halo and all these things
that were very cinematic ideas already
that were derivative of movies
um and so for me it was like well can I
take a puzzle game and make that cool
you know imagine the way that like not
that I'm comparing myself to him but
Batman before Nolan was very silly
um and he was like I think this can be
interesting and important and profound
and awesome and you know it doesn't have
to be silly because it's a guy in the
back like we can do something different
I love that kind of challenge of taking
a thing that's prey was like taking a
thing that had been a little silly in
recent years and saying I think that it
can be emotional and and
uh an important and thrilling you know
so okay so that that point can kind of
bring me into the beginning of of prey
because I have I have a couple questions
about the timeline of how all of this uh
panned out I guess the first thing I
need to ask though is when the idea
first started and was it the situation
where you bring a predator idea to the
studio or do they tell you we have the
rights to Predator do you have any ideas
no it wasn't that I've certainly had
those kinds of meetings too but no this
one was
uh I was really I've always thought
about how could I make a movie
with as little words as possible and as
much action as possible and and I and
Furia Road really charged me up of like
oh my gosh like it kind of did it you
know you really can do that and I I just
I just didn't want
to make something only a Thrill Ride you
know I was I was trying to think of is
there a way to do that but also have it
feel emotionally charged as well and was
thinking about
um Underdog stories and like oh yeah
what if we took this the the engine of a
sports movie and put that into this
other thing and and so
um thought about a character trying to
prove themselves and then let me to
um Native American and like oh right
like and the Comanche in particular
you know are we're so often in movies
relegated to playing the sidekick or the
villain never the heroes so so if we can
make the movie
starring that person and also with with
the theme of the movie is also that idea
it creates this one-to-one relationship
between audience and protagonist I think
I I think about that a lot
um and I'm just somewhat putting these
pieces together now like because of my
inspiration from video games and my
Adoration of video games that what I
love is that how experiential they are
and how linked that what's exciting is
that I really feel like that character
even when it's a third person game I'm
like I'm linked to that you know
um and so I love when that those things
work in concert so I love the idea that
we could be rooting for
the actor having a moment and the
character having a moment and should we
feel like we're in her shoes we are then
having this Mo like I just thought that
would be
awesome
um so yeah you say actor now I
immediately want to start talking about
Amber but I do have one other timeline
question because I believe I saw in
another interview you had mentioned that
the Hope initially was to be into
production with this movie before the
release of the 2018 uh Predator movie
yes so it was making me curious given
that that didn't happen when you saw
that movie did it inspire you to change
or add anything to the price script no
and let me let me uh let me first
clarify because I didn't quite answer
exactly what you asked anyway which was
they were making I had this idea
and they were making Shane's movie I it
was either in prep or or or or maybe in
early stages of production and my reps
were like don't they're making a move
you know making a movie and I was like
yeah but this I ideas too I can't keep
it in so my angle was I emailed an
executive 20th the patch I didn't even
say I just emailed it to him
um and and said I know you're doing
what's sure to be the start of a new
trailer like I get it you know but maybe
like Star Wars has 789 and then I don't
even know if they were out at the time
but like solo and Rogue one or these
like so why don't we call this movie
prey and then you can do this other
thing while you're doing that that thing
you know
um and so that was the hook that got
them interested and the idea and the and
that this could actually be a great
movie hopefully
um so yeah and my my oh part of that
email was that we would have a teaser
that comes out at some point without
title that just is the first half of the
of the of Amber's story is just
um Comanche trying to prove himself goes
out in the woods and sees a fire in the
sky and you'll be like oh what is that
great what's that what's that a very JJ
style trailer
um and then when Shane's Ruby came out
you'd attach the full trailer and have
that bear moment
um in it where it reveals in blood it's
a oh that thing we heard about earlier
this year it's it's a Predator move you
know like that that was my dream that
was what I had laid out
um that didn't work uh that didn't work
out but I just want to be clear I at no
point thought that the I knew I mean I
would have loved that the movie could
reveal it to an audience but for me it
was like the cell was in the marketing
movie like we can still Embrace have
that fun
um
I don't think anything changed in you
know the thing that we were relying on
is
in success Shane's movie was so and
really this we were we were working off
of only the only having read the script
for his movie
um and there was a lot more going on
there was like
there's a lot um there was a lot it was
a even more Shane Blackie than one could
imagine
um and was like so this works like which
is very kick in sync it's very like
going bonkers with it so then it's still
cool that we have this other
Back to Basics stripped down tail and if
it turns out that that doesn't work
when they eventually decide to make a
better move again which has to happen at
some point even though there was a
couple years where I felt like maybe
they want the sex
um but when they do this would be the
move you make right you make you make
the movie that is more stripped down and
you went follows the wall with the other
and so I I knew that
because just just to fill in a Gap a
little bit like my reps were like
because the script was so good like
maybe we take this out not as a predator
thing but thinking about oh they got to
eventually and also
thematically I could not let go of boy
that it is an antagonist whose main
purpose is to find the alpha find the
worthy and she's out there trying to say
I am and it's saying I don't see you
like like it's like it's too it's Makes
Her movie better and she makes a
predator movie but like it's like I
can't not we have to just wait you know
um so thankfully thankfully they've dug
it out of the file file cabinet but
um
yeah so that's the timeline so many
thoughts one I'll just say because you
referenced the bear scene that's still
like one of my absolute favorite shots
of film in 2022 it is just like an epic
reveal and everything about that
sequence is is something else I also
just love what you do here in terms of
you know it feeling like a predator
movie that appeases fans but it also
being a perfect entryway for a newcomer
that's never seen anything in this
franchise before and I feel I feel like
that is one of the most difficult and I
talk about that a lot when it comes to
Series in general because with every new
installment essentially if you're
continuing a story you're narrowing and
narrowing and narrowing your viewership
this is a perfect opportunity to do the
exact opposite and it seems you have
done that
thank you for saying it to be candid it
was challenging and we had an initial
cut of the movie that really took for
granted if that was always the ambition
but the initial cut we took for granted
people's
um
awareness or even even uh ability to
follow what the Predator's up to
um and some of our
um reshoots or additional whatever you
want to call it were
were it used to be that the Predator was
tracking her and she was tracking the
predator and it was like this weird
Circle that was very hard to follow
um and then we realized oh the move that
we need to make
is put them on Parallel paths that then
Collide so we had the snake we added the
snake mouse bit where we also articulate
the hierarchy that he's looking for
um and the wolf scene
um and and everyone articulate trophy in
the cave trophy you know
um and then and then it and then it's on
her path when it gets to the Buffalo and
you know like it's like okay they are
they are parallel and colliding two
great hunters on other opposite sides of
the tracks so to speak
um uh and also articulating to newcomers
of the franchise because we we had sweet
friends and family stuff where someone
was like what do you think the Predator
you know and someone's like I think he's
a vampire because the bear scene like oh
they thought it was like drinking the
blood of the bet when you don't know all
the other things you don't you know what
I mean like I I know I'm like what you
know but I but I get it you know
um so I can't tell you how many times
in early days
because when people are unaware of what
they're seeing we got the like but
doesn't the blood
isn't the blood acid you know so many
people said that I was like oh oh so
wrong wrong I get why you think that
it's green
um and you sort of by proxy like are
blending that you know but
um the movie has to do a better job at
saying that's it we're not what exactly
what we are
um sometimes it's difficult for me to
remove myself from this bubble where
these things exist 24 7 and are kind of
like part of my being yes yes part of it
you're being at 100 yeah yeah I feel
like I'm jumping all over the place
right now but just because we were
talking about uh broadening the Predator
audience something else that makes me
really excited right now is part of the
reason we're talking is because prey is
currently on the award season circuit
and as a genre lover that's a really
special thing for me to see because my
genre movies that I love dearly are
often not included in that conversation
and you know I know we don't make these
things to win Awards and all of that but
as a genre lover yourself I guess what
does it mean to you to have the film be
in this type of consideration now and
and what was your reaction the first
time you realized it was going down that
path
um it's awesome I I share your sentiment
and I
grew up I I I can't tell you how many
times in film School repeating like
Raiders of the Lost Ark was nominated
for an Academy you know like I I I I
loved that and I always felt like but
why why that and then like nothing else
you know I I and always thinking John Wu
should have what why is that why are
those movies nobody makes movies like
that that's as much of an October that
Tarantino was an Entre like why is not
that that not being viewed that way and
the and the craft that goes into making
his sequences like he makes them and
um don't get started on stunts you know
and all that stuff well I can go on and
on about that so I I I've always wanted
to see that
um but I will also say that I I would
never want there to be uh genre Film
Academy like like to me it's like no you
wanna you wanna make something that does
fulfill the ultimate thing of like it is
it is what A Thrill Ride and also people
are finding it to be and insightful and
emotional and empowering you know you
know like that it's doing all the things
that we want to an award a movie for
um while also being
um thrilling uh so it is like we had a
nice little like the PGA we were now
here for pgas and
um which is amazing for Jane who's
producer who's you know uh command
yourself and then never that that's a
Monumental thing and
um and all the other uh awardsy stuff
um now I'm in Ohio Credit whatever it
was
um so all that stuff has been awesome
and and I
I yeah just being in the conversation
when you make something like this
that's always a balance of like medicine
and ice cream you know
um it's great it's great to even be
uttered by and Barry Jenkins moderated
one of her things and he loved the movie
you know like Ken it's like it's just so
so so cool and and also heartening
having the interest that you and I have
of like it's just validating you know
like oh yeah people they we love we love
the same things it's nice to find other
people that like what you like
um
so yeah it's dope so cool excuse to jump
to Amber now because she has been
getting a whole lot of award season love
for her performance as she should so
having worked with her not that she's
new to the business in any sense but I
just do have a feeling after seeing this
movie that she's bound to headline more
movies and shows in the future so what
is something about the way she works as
a lead and also a collaborator for you
that you're really excited for more
directors to get to experience if they
work with her in the future when they
work with her in the future I need to
rephrase that
great question I thank you and Amber's
behalf for that question
um it yeah I mean she she ate no ego
um
no pretense very down to earth which I
love I'm really drawn to actors in
general and Amber is one of them who are
seeking
how would this really be you know like
what is the real human behavior behind
this and what is it like we're talking
like we're not speaking in overly
complicated language
that makes things more so esoteric it's
it's like how do we get straight to the
heart of true what is this like so that
it feels like a dagger into your
audience also like oh yeah I that's me
there I connect to that and it's just
fun to have a collaboration that is that
grounded you know that we can talk in
real people terms and
um and and and draw in more of Our Lives
um more of the way I think about people
the way she thinks about people as
opposed to
what we think about drama you know
um uh but that said there is another
this was I mean she has done genre
actually she has a genre but not quite
on this level and so there certainly was
a conversation about like but in this
this sometimes you just need a moment
like this you know sometimes you just
need and
um and she quickly snapped onto that as
well so which is it that's medicine and
ice cream in in the acting world is like
what is a moment that I that needs to
happen for the genre element and then
what is a where's a moment that we did
not let it off the hook that was just a
genre thing no no we need to be austere
in our like approach to how does it feel
authentic
um so that's all bouncing at the she
bounce very well on top of the crazy
physicality
um and the day-to-day demands of being
in almost every frame of the movie from
from an emotional perspective from a
physical perspective never complaining
um never even coming near a complaint
frankly
um about any that
um and being
yeah just good good good person that
works well well intended
um and then delivering you know
delivering in the most I still her she
does this war cry at the end of the
movie
um that it's my favorite thing and I've
seen it a bajillion times and I get
goosebumps every time I see it it's I I
love it so much and it's pure human
emotion I mean there's just no and not
everyone can do that there's a lot of
characters screaming at movies that
we've seen and they don't all feel so
um emotional so yeah I I love her
speaking of how much she had her work
cut out for her with this movie I was
remembering when we were doing the uh
the press conference conversation she
had mentioned that the script was
intimidating because at a point she read
something like 30 straight pages of of
action which I imagine can be quite
daunting to an actor so as an actor's
director in this situation what are some
of your top priorities to you know make
sure you get what you need from an actor
who has to go through something like
that but while also being able to
support them in the best possible way
while enduring a taxing shoot I can tell
you that I am not the director that will
jump into the mud pit to show them I can
do it too and that is not me uh I'm
quick to say we hired you for that and
I'm doing this and I need to be clean to
make all these other decisions
um so I'm not that guy but but I you
know you do as much as you can
without the person having to endure
physicality
um to protect like when they are there
we are all focused and doing the thing
um it's yeah the the
it's so funny I remember on Cloverfield
Lane like
which has a lot of dialogue but there
were stretches where there weren't and
those were the hardest things because
you it's like what it's like each
sentence is a few shots to think about
and to figure out and you know and so
there's less kind of parameters for it
so it's very daunting and
um and this movie
was all that you know it was almost all
that uh and I'll never again
shoot a movie that's like exterior
Forest day for the whole thing you know
like forget it you know because it's
it's like even location scouting was
like okay yeah I like those trees do you
like these trees yeah those trees are
good like how do we even find you know
the thing uh so
all of it was a challenge but yeah I
think I think I just did my best to to
to
um maximize the time spent with her
um and not over some some people are not
careful and and what they're doing even
emotional scenes we had a conversation
about
um the order do you want to get this out
of the way do you want to build up to
this
um do you want to do a lot of Are You
Gonna Wanna you're like so everyone is
kind of preparing for the moment
um
um yeah going back to uh the idea of
filming this entire movie outside in in
a forest what is
how should I phrase this so if
everything you have to do in production
maybe even in development and
pre-production Gathering resources is
there any particular thing that proved
most challenging or maybe something that
you couldn't get and it inspired a
creative pivot and made something better
because you had a change from the
original plan hmm
yeah
you know
okay I I will say I mean I I I think
I've talked before about the burn Glade
sequence you know was almost didn't
happen because of wind
um and we needed that very specific look
with The Mists and that you know that
that almost fell apart but I will say
there was a sequence
um in the end we were that final fight
we really iterated a lot on and we were
we almost had a certain location that we
couldn't shoot there because it was
protected forestry Wildlife
um and so it forced us to go to another
spot and then that aesthetically I
wasn't as in love with and it it sort of
what drove the choice to have it all be
snowbound
um so that extra snow layer would add a
little piece of visual interest but then
in moving there we came up with the cool
choreography
we've built something around the the
terrain of this other location and then
when they let that go we were so sure
what could the choreography be here
um and that forced us into a her setting
up these different traps
um for for the predator and then be
crafting that what I think is such a
cool moment when she slides into the
rocks and its Shield stops against the
rocks and then
um we have that great face off and then
she grips the mandible all that wasn't
in the initial choreography and came
from okay if it can't be there let's
think of other things and think and we
really responds more time to figure out
the cool you know and I just love those
those mandibles have been a thing we've
seen in all these Predator movies and
finally it's it's turned against him
um or it uh and the and yeah her the
intelligence of her to like think of the
Rocks because she knows that knows that
Shield's coming out anyway
um so yeah now because I'm mad I left
post-production out of that piss poorly
worded question that I just threw at you
to focus focus on the your work with
your editor on this can you give me an
example of something that you know maybe
you liked on set but when you were
working on the edit you found almost
like a hidden corner and realized
something was stronger than you ever
realized and in the post-production
phase you were able to amplify it to
show it off more boy there's probably a
bajillion of those and it's such a good
question
um the things that come to mind
that Angela was so gifted at where
there's a couple of montages in the
movie uh where
actually even
the yeah so there's certainly there's
emotional moments like there's one where
tave comes back uh with the lion head
and and he's sort of been was being
crowned so to speak Warchief and the
current Warchief is giving a fairly
rousing
um speech to everyone and and uh but
instead because to put it more in nadi's
perspective we started we played with it
just being very minimal score brooding
um and all sort of looks from people
person to person and and that made it so
much more Tethered to her
emotional experience
um and more deeply felt I think and
the uh
there's another scene where the mom gets
really bad news
that her son is killed
um and she gave and the and and yeah and
and
um the younger Warrior the younger
Hunter telling her like he was good and
she was like hearing the news was
amazing
um and instead we cut it so you didn't
really hear any of it it was all implied
and you saw the just slivers of her
performance and like all just said to
you know that felt so much more
emotional I remember I remember seeing a
scene in and I might be misremembering
it but in 21 Grams when Naomi Watts gets
bad news I don't remember the plot that
much in the movie but remember she's in
a hospital and she starts having an
intense emotional breakdown and it's
over either score or quiet so you're
seeing it and it's it's so heightened
and you're just seeing that sliver and
that's enough you don't need to hear the
Wailing and the and the new you don't
even need to hear the news you just need
to see the whole the shoulders hunch and
like oh I know what's happening with
that person
um so I think that was
the inspiration for the movie that I
could not even I mean I remember loving
it when it came out sonograms but that
in Babel back I was like you know the
greatest
um but uh yeah all right I gotta let you
go soon you have a lot more promoting to
do which you should because I want to
see this movie get all the love it
deserves I'm gonna end with you know
kind of like a future type question
because you've already brought up Mad
Max during our conversation and I've
heard you mentioned before how that
movie kind of inspired you to want to
tell a story via action and how it led
to this so I am wondering since having I
mean either seeing Mad Max or having
finished making prey have you had a
similar experience with a different type
of film a recent movie that inspired you
in a way that we might see reflected in
a future project you tackle oh boy Perry
so good so good
um
Maybe
I will say strangely a a reference that
never leaves me that's a modern movie is
and fuels so much of this stuff and
continues to feel me is Guardians of the
Galaxy uh and I still I haven't seen
third one yet but
I know I hear it's amazing um but
specifically because it's
it also it's so ridiculous so many of
the ideas in it are so ridiculous and
yet emotionally the sentiment is so true
and so good
um that I always like and that is also a
movie where
that could have been the movie that
Marvel jumped the shark you know that
that could have been the one that had
the little raccoon and a talking tree
and you know like yeah that that could
have gone bad
and actually
it was a safer bet for how bold it was
rather than like some I think prior to
that film people could see bold choices
as being that's that could ruin it you
know and that started this I think it's
right maybe there's another film that
I'm miscounting
um where it's like no it was successful
because of the raccoon and the talking
tree that's why and because of the guy
from the TV show that was the lead you
know like all of those big choices are
why it was successful it wasn't
successful despite those things
um so I think about that a lot and and
I'm encouraged by the like commercial
safety in bold decision making so I like
that thought quite a bit because it
suggests to me that our future will be
filled with you know bold maybe wide
appeal films that also have unique
touches that keep us on our toes and
keep this a really exciting creative
space and I feel like the more we have
of that kind of material the better we
are totally totally yeah all right I
have to leave you I'm going to say
congratulations again and I will remind
our audience if you haven't go watch
prey if you've watched it watch it again
and also talk about it spread the word I
think it's a very special movie and you
deserve a whole lot of love you got it
last year I want to see you get it this
year and I have a feeling this will be a
highly re-watched movie well into the
future thank you so much thank you